[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: The Google
Cloud CLI, what is it?
The Google Cloud
Command Line Interface,
also known as the
Google Cloud CLI,
is a set of command
line tools that
are used to access the many
services on Google Cloud.
As part of the Google
Cloud SDK, the CLI
makes it easy for developers
and administrators
to manage their Cloud
resources and infrastructure
from their Linux, macOS,
or Windows terminal.
You can also access it without
having to download or install
anything by using Cloud
Shell, our in-browser shell
environment.
Several command line tools are
bundled within the Google Cloud
CLI.
First, there's gcloud,
the primary CLI tool
used to customize your
local configuration,
manage authentication, and let
you access a majority of Google
Cloud resources.
There are a lot of things
you can do with gcloud--
spin up a virtual machine
on Compute Engine,
create a database on Cloud SQL,
grant IAM roles and permissions
to users and service accounts,
manage your organization's
policies, and much more.
Virtually anything you can do
in the Google Cloud console
by pointing and
clicking, you can also
do with a corresponding
gcloud command.
Several other CLIs
and tools come
bundled within the
Google Cloud CLI,
including bq for interacting
with BigQuery from the command
line.
With bq, you can create and
manage BigQuery resources
like data sets,
jobs, and transfers,
and run queries on
your BigQuery tables.
Next, there's gsutil for
accessing Cloud Storage
from the command line.
If you're accessing
Cloud Storage buckets,
you'll use gsutil to
create, list, and delete
buckets, as well as upload,
download, and manage
the objects stored in them.
And what's more?
gcloud can run a number
of emulators that will generate
data for Bigtable, Datastore,
Firestore, Pub/Sub,
and Spanner for use
in your local
development environment.
All of these command line tools,
gcloud, bq, gsutil, and others,
can be used interactively
or programmatically
in any automated scripts.
So how do you get started
using the Google Cloud CLI?
If you already have a
Google Cloud project,
you'll find it pre-installed
in Cloud Shell.
For local development, it's
supported for Linux, macOS,
and Windows operating systems,
and requires Python to run.
You can install it through
your operating system's package
manager.
And once installed, the Google
Cloud CLI supports updates.
So you'll always have access to
the latest changes and features
available on Google Cloud.
You can find complete
installation instructions
at cloud.google.com/cli.
For more on Google
Cloud CLI and how
you can get started
using it, check out
the links in the
description of this video.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]